al inicio de su carrera algebraica
aprendieron cómo multiplicar polinomios
por ejemplo si tenemos x + 2 x 4 x + 5
aprendimos que esto es lo mismo que al
usar la propiedad distributiva dos veces
multiplicar x por 4x es 4x cuadrada x x
55 x y multiplicamos 2 x 4 x lo que da 8
x multiplicamos 2 por 5 lo que da 10 si
lo que acabo de hacer les parece extraño
los invito a que repasen la
multiplicación de binomios en khan
academy esto puede simplificarse como 4x
cuadrada más 13 x más 10 y lo que vamos
a hacer ahora para avanzar en nuestras
carreras algebraicas es pensar en cómo
hacer lo opuesto como dividimos
polinomios ahora puede que ustedes sepan
gracias a su conocimiento de
multiplicación y división que esto es
hacer lo opuesto a lo que hicimos aquí
arriba que x + 2 por 4 x + 5 es igual a
esto de aquí por lo que esto de aquí
/ x2 debería ser igual a 4 x 5 y aún si
no tuviéramos la información que está
aquí arriba hay formas en las que
podemos calcular esto una forma de
hacerlo es tratar de factorizar lo que
tenemos en el numerador pueden decir oye
voy a tratar de factorizar esto por
agrupación vamos a hacerlo por acá 4x
cuadrada + 13 x + 10 para factorizar por
agrupación nos preguntamos si podemos
encontrar dos números cuyo producto sea
cuatro veces diez por b es igual a 40 y
cuya suma sea igual a 13 así que a más b
sea igual a 13 pensemos en que podría
ser podría ser 8 y 5 a es igual a 8 y b
es igual a 5
esto es factorizar por agrupación
nuevamente si esto no les suena familiar
los invito a que revisen la
factorización por agrupación en khan
academy así que vamos a descomponer este
13 x como 8x y como 5x reescribimos esto
como 4
es cuadrada más 8 x + 5 x + 10 y
recuerden que estamos haciendo lo
opuesto de lo que hicimos aquí pero
suponemos que desconocemos lo que se
hizo aquí arriba y alguien nos dio esta
cuadrática directamente y nos pide que
la factory semos y aquí podemos decir
que factor izamos 4x para que quede 4x
por x + 2 y luego factorizar cinco de
estos otros dos términos que da 5 x x +
2 y ahora factor izamos el x + 2 lo que
se convierte en voy a hacer más espacio
en la pantalla esto se vuelve x + 2 que
factor izamos y lo multiplicamos por 4 x
+ 5 que es exactamente lo que tenemos
aquí arriba por lo que podemos
reescribir esta expresión que involucra
división también conocida como expresión
racional reescribimos esta expresión
como x + 2 x 4 x + 5 todo esto entre x +
2 siempre y cuando x no sea igual a
menos 2 podemos dividir el numerador y
el denominador entre
2 y nos queda 4 x + 5 y podemos
restringir esto para x diferente de
menos 2 esto solamente es el preámbulo
conforme avancemos realizaremos
muchísimos ejemplos de esto y también
veremos que hay otras técnicas además de
factorizar el numerador aquí y lo que
haremos con polinomios con mayor grado
polinomios de tercer grado es aprender
algo llamado división polinomio lo cual
se parece mucho a la división larga que
probablemente aprendieron en cuarto o
quinto grado tomaremos expresiones como
x + 2 y vamos a usarlo para dividir 4x
cuadrada + 13 x + 10 y en lugar del
valor posicional tendremos una nueva
noción de valor posicional que se
refiere a cuál es el grado del término
que nos interesa y haremos cosas que
desarrollaremos por completo en otros
vídeos como preguntarnos cuántas veces
cabe x en 4x cuadrada pues cabe 4x veces
ponemos 4x aquí lo multiplicamos por x
queda
4 x cuadrada 4x por 2 es 8 x restamos
ambas y continuamos como lo hacemos
típicamente con la división larga 13 x
menos 8 x 5 x luego bajamos este 10 y
ahora nos preguntamos cuántas veces cabe
x en 5x vemos que cabe 5 veces 5 veces x
es igual a 5x y 5 por 2 es igual a 10
ahora restamos esto y no nos queda
residuo noten que acaban de ver como x +
2 divide a todo esto y resulta 4 x + 5
justo como lo vimos aquí arriba vamos a
explorar estas diferentes técnicas
incluyendo la división polinomiales y
también veremos qué sucede cuando
tenemos un residuo